do you think that crowdfunding is
causing a divided social media I think
we've all been hit up and we want to be
able to contribute I think a lot of us
are just tapped out right it can be nice
to donate 25 here and there right but do
you think that then people's feelings
get hurt if I definitely do because it's
funny because the ones that have
supported me I always tried at least
give back to down for sure but there's
other ones that are my friends for sure
but they never they didn't financially
support so I don't feel as obligated but
I'll definitely help them spread the
word but it's one of those where you
want to be able to give money so if you
have it you do otherwise you just feel
bad and you don't know how they feel so
sometimes you know and social media such
a funny thing people can be touchy you
know a little bit about if you if you
retweeted them or if you didn't and it's
just a weird weird kind of realm you
know
I don't know what the only thing I can
say is and it's kind of a side note to
the crowdfunding thing on my website and
i'm totally not blatantly trying to plug
my website but on my blog i sell my
movies and I don't sell a lot I don't so
when they actually come in you know they
buy DVD I have a paypal account that I
that's what I use sometimes on IndieGoGo
when I see someone's crowd kind of
crowdfunding campaign is like I just use
whatever of money I've sold for my DVDs
to like do it is like 10 puck $10 pop
here tena you know it's nothing big but
it's something just to kind of give back
you know otherwise like you said it's it
can get touchy and so it's it's you guys
I think are in the worst position
because you were known for you know
supporting in you know in helping a lot
and I'm sure you get an email every day
from someone and the etiquette is funny
because a lot of um sure that hit you up
as well as me up it's there in their
last two weeks for last week of the
campaign there are only ten percent fund
and they think you're going to come in
and save the day you realize they
haven't done their research or maybe
haven't done their due diligence on how
to do it and so you don't feel as
obligated to help and I don't know if
that's being cynical or if that's bad
because you should help or not but
that's the thing where I just feel again
social media in the realm when its face
to face is different you you actually
connect when it's in the realm keep
between kind of behind their web persona
can can act a little touchy or feel a
little offended and it's nothing
personal that's the thing is not you're
not trying to get personal
offending
I think Tiffany Shlain said I great she
said social media is really an extension
of how you are socially really you know
it's not just you know your your twitter
avatar it's you know it's really however
you sort of behave in real life and I'm
paraphrasing it with and I think that's
very true yeah yeah it is it is hard to
be able to support everyone and
especially class to me yeah right right
right and it's cool because I would say
like the majority of people I've met up
on off Twitter when I you know connected
with them first they're pretty much who
they are because you know they're saying
their thoughts and remembers you're
almost like you're in their head and you
see them yawning you know they're kind
of mindset and they're doing I've rarely
met kind of like weirdos that you know
kind of like our one whether either
avatar is like actually 10 years younger
than when you see them in person like oh
okay you know and that that's kind of
funny when you see that
you